all right just a short time ago I sat
down with former vice president Mike
Pence to talk about the multiple crisis
we are facing as a country both at home
and abroad take a look
all right joining us now former vice
president Mike Pence Mr Vice President
how are you sir good to see you Sean
thank you so economically Lawrence
summer says we may be headed for a crash
you see the events in the world
unfolding Ukraine Russia annual alliance
with Russia
and China
um we have a Chinese balloon flying all
over
the country we don't shoot it down
um
I am seeing really troubled times on
every front I want to get your take well
look it's all evidence of failed
leadership by the Biden administration
at home and abroad I mean the unprovoked
war of aggression now one year in the
making in Ukraine with Russia uh look
Vladimir Putin's responsible for the
decisions that he made
but I have no doubt in my mind that the
capitulation of this Administration on
Nordstrom too the disasters withdrawal
from Afghanistan set the environment
where Putin thought he could get away
with that invasion in Ukraine and here
at home the American people are paying a
price I mean the the 1.9 trillion
dollars in spending passed on a party
line vote that launched the worst
inflation in 40 years and before the end
of the last session nearly another
trillion dollars in unnecessary spending
and the American people know that we
need change change in this country and
they know that there are challenging
times ahead at home and abroad but they
also know that whether it's the economy
whether it's World stage whether it's a
crisis at the border whether it's crime
on the streets of our major cities these
are all the natural consequence of the
failed leadership of President Biden and
I think that's why there's change around
the corner let me ask about Ukraine big
deal made in the media about Joe Biden
going over to Keith meeting presidential
as he okay the United States of America
has already contributed
133 billion dollars the rest of Europe
30 billion Rush uh Great Britain 5
billion Germany 5 billion this is their
backyard but the worst decision I think
Joe Biden made he has prevented
countries like Poland
from providing fighter jets that
zolinski would need to win the war right
and I know a lot of American taxpayers
are saying if you're not going to fight
this war to win this war why are you
taking 130 billion dollars in spending
it on the war well it's fair question
but let's back up for a second and
remember that the Trump Pence
Administration was the only
Administration in the 21st century where
Russia did not even attempt to redraw
International Lines by force they did it
at the Bush Administration when the
tanks rolled into Georgia they did it
under the Obama Administration when they
captured Crimea but under our
Administration it was peace through
strength historic investments in our
National Defense a willingness to allow
our military to prosecute our interests
take the fight to our our enemies on our
terms on their soil that changed under
this Administration and it's emboldened
not only Putin but other authoritarian
leaders are around the world that said
we're in the fight and I believe we've
got to stay in the fight you know it was
1985. State of the Union Address by
Ronald Reagan in which he articulated
what came to be known as the Reagan
Doctrine he said we must not break Faith
with those who are risking their lives
to defy Soviet supported aggression I
mean as the Bible says there's nothing
new Under the Sun what is now has been
before we are we are involved in a proxy
war against the Soviet Union the
ukrainians are fighting it and I really
believe it's absolutely essential that
we see it through we demand our European
allies do more than their share because
it is their front yard but I think it's
absolutely essential that after a slow
start in providing support to the
Ukrainian military by the Biden
Administration we're now providing that
support but let's get them what they
need the tanks let's get in the f-16s
but Joe Biden support them as they
finish this fight Joe Biden vetoed
Poland from giving the migs right
right steak right yeah well look it
President Biden was dragging his feet
from go and remember when he said he
said that it might be acceptable if
there was just a small incursion by the
Russian military I mean this this is
this is a this is a absent without
leadership Administration when it comes
to the foreign stage and they've been
playing catch-up ever since and I but I
I really do believe that it's absolutely
sensual that we Embrace that Reagan
Doctrine I've I've stood closer than I
am to you and looked Vladimir Putin
right in the eye and told him things he
didn't want to hear and I got to tell
you uh
um if you think he's going to stop if he
captures Ukraine uh in re-establishing
the old Soviet sphere do you think he'd
go to Poland you got another thing
coming I I don't know Poland but I yes
territorial Lithuania Estonia uh Belarus
these other countries are already
beginning to either feel the fear here
or begin to fall in line and so I think
it's important that we hold the line
here
support the ukrainians as they make the
fight just like that Reagan Doctrine
said but it at the end of the day the
real antidote here's what we had during
our Administration and that was a
commitment not only to our National
Defense but also an unwavering
commitment to allow our military to
defend and prosecute our interests in
the world wherever they were threatened
Europe in my view has to step up Europe
has to provide the necessary weapons to
win and I think that's been a missing
part of the equation
let me talk a little bit about you and
your future
a lot of speculation you might be
getting in the race of President are you
thinking about it have you decided where
are you in the process uh we are
thinking about it uh Karen and I have
made no decision yet but we're getting a
lot of encouragement
from around the country I was in Iowa
and Minnesota last week taking a stand
for parents rights where we'll be back
on the road this week to Texas and uh
you know what I'm hearing uh what I'm
hearing from people around the country
is they want to get back to what we were
doing during the Trump Pence
Administration
but they also want to begin to challenge
and take on some of these major
challenges that we face as a country
whether it be geopolitical challenges
like China whether it be a a national
debt the size of our nation's economy or
whether it be this uh these cultural
issues that seem to be treading farther
and farther on the traditional values
that have made this country great and uh
and so we're going to reflect on all of
those things we're going to continue to
give it prayerful considerations you're
not going to tell me tonight I can read
I've been doing this along and I'm
teasing I promise I'll keep you posted
Sean
um if you do get in it would mean you
are going up against your former partner
president Trump
is that a factor a b
where would you be different
on issues with than president Trump well
I said early on that the only thing I
had decided was that I wasn't going to
let anybody else make the decision for
me so whether it's the former president
or any other candidate we'll we'll make
a decision based on what I and my family
feel called to do in this moment in the
life of the nation all right Mr Vice
President as always great to see you
thank you for being with us thank you
Sean appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else